vous êtes sur france 24 vous avez raison
bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir boris johnson
à kigali pour défendre l'accord
controversé sur les migrants expulsés de
la grande bretagne le premier ministre
britannique demande aux opposants à ce
projet de garder l'esprit ouvert
vital kamerhe acquitté en appel l'ancien
directeur de cabinet alliés du président
de la république de la rdc avait été
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour un
détournement de 50 millions de dollars
nous irons sur plaque dans ce journal
le fn décès suspend son appel à
manifester le collectif qui avait mené
la contestation en guinée contre
l'ancien président alpha condé dit
pouvoir donner sa chance au dialogue
proposé par les excuses
boris johnson est à kigali pour la
réunion du commonwealth il est aussi
venu assurer le service après-vente d'un
projet controversé celui de l'expulsion
des migrants du royaume uni vers le
rwanda et le premier ministre
britannique a demandé aux opposants au
projet de jeu site garder l'esprit
ouvert qu'à me nédélec
c'est une visite d'importance
stratégique pour le gouvernement
britannique à kigali le premier ministre
mauricien hansen a encore défendu son
plan controversé d'envoyer les
demandeurs d'asile au rwanda suite à une
injonction de dernière minute de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme le
premier vol est resté cloué au sol
j'ai écouté les critiques venant de
toutes parts et je pense tout simplement
qu'il base leur opinion sur une certaine
idée de ce pays voire même un stéréotype
dépassé il devrait venir faire un
constat avec leurs propres yeux comme le
font les chefs de gouvernement du
commonwealth aujourd'hui il devrait se
rendre compte de tout le progrès que le
rwanda a fait
boris johnson a présenté de nouveaux
accords commerciaux préférentiels avec
82 pays y compris le rwanda le sommet du
commonwealth n'avait pas eu lieu depuis
2018 à cause de la pandémie et réunit
les dirigeants des 54 pays membres au
programme l'inflation la guerre en
ukraine et le développement le
commonwealth a aussi annoncé son voeu de
faire disparaître le paludisme
si nous avons appris une chose avec la
pandémie
c'est qu'ensemble grâce à une action
coordonnée collaborative nous pouvons
faire beaucoup plus
le commonwealth est aussi censé adopté
le living lines chante à un accord pour
lutter contre le changement climatique
et la dégradation des terres
et au menu de cette réunion du
commonwealth au rwanda l'adhésion du
gabon qui devait être imminente sauf
retournement de situation sont entrés
dans l'union sera finalisé cette semaine
où les chefs d'état des 54 pays sont
réunis autour sur ce projet d'adhésion
qui divise les gabonais reportage à
libreville de soria bakary et ismaël
obiang
[Musique]
dont la salle de classe plus d'une
dizaine d'employés du secteur public et
privé inscrits à ce cours d'anglais
dispensés par catherine la maîtrise de
la langue anglaise est une compétence de
plus en plus recherchés au gabon depuis
que le pays a décidé de rejoindre le
commonwealth
gabon est donc un bon ya de plus en plus
de pressions à presque tous et toutes
les entrevues pour être embauché
aujourd'hui ça se fait à l'envers un
vocabulaire pas toujours facile à
mémoriser pour des étudiants combat
blick la pratique de l'anglais est
encore très minoritaires le jeune homme
a du mal à trouver des interlocuteurs
anglophones dans son entourage le bémol
dans ce processus dans ce sens pour ceux
ci c'est principalement le fait de ne
pas avoir la possibilité de produire ou
de garder ce qu'on a qu'on a acquis
parce que lorsque l'on nourou rentrer à
la maison nous n'avons pas la
possibilité de discuter avec nos frères
nos soeurs en anglais le gabon mise
beaucoup sur cette adhésion au
commonwealth en espérant d'importantes
retombées économiques notamment des
accords commerciaux dont veulent
profiter des entrepreneurs gabonais
comme yannis je pense que cette adhésion
fera du baume que notamment au niveau de
notre économie et surtout au niveau des
l'employabilité des jeunes qui aussi a
pris un coup dans cette adhésion des
tant attendu et ce sera une réponse au
chômage crée
actuellement
mais pour une partie de la société
civile l'adhésion du gabon au
commonwealth ne développera pas le pays
par miracle plutôt que chercher adhérer
à une organisation
marc ona aurait préféré voir le pouvoir
s'attaquer à la mal gouvernance pour ses
leaders associatifs très critiques du
régime gabonais la seule priorité du
pays devrait être la lutte anti
corruption
aujourd'hui on peut adhérer à n'importe
quelle organisation
mais si la gouvernance interne n'est pas
à l'ordre du jour si les droits de
l'homme ne sont pas respectés si les
règles ne changent pas à ce niveau on
aura à gérer a dit mme l'organisation ça
ne changera rien pour le gabon dont le
dernier classement de louanges et
transparente y internationale le gabon a
gagné cinq places passant de la 119e
anna 124e place mondiale une évolution
dont se félicite des autorités qui
entendent capitaliser sur le succès
diplomatique d'une adhésion au
commonwealth
vital kamerhe est totalement acquitté
par la cours d'appel l'ancien directeur
de cabinet et allié du président
congolais félix tshisekedi avait été
condamné à 20 ans de prison pour
détournement de près de 50 millions de
dollars les précisions de notre
correspondant clément belin
cela faisait déjà plusieurs mois que le
scénario d'un acquittement pour vital
kamerhe se précisait l'annulation en
avril par la cour de cassation de sa
condamnation en appel avait été perçu
par ses proches comme un premier pas
pour rappel l'ancien directeur de
cabinet de félix tshisekedi avait été
condamné en première instance en juin
2020 à 20 ans de prison et dix ans
d'inéligibilité pour corruption et
détournements de fonds dans le cadre du
programme présidentiel dit des 100 jours
il s'agissait de fonds destinés
notamment à la construction de logements
pour les militaires et les policiers
cette peine avait été réduite à 13 ans
de réclusion lors d'un premier procès en
appel en juin 2021 et en décembre vital
kamerhe avait été remise en liberté
provisoire pour raisons médicales son
acquittement ce jeudi est salué par ses
proches joint au téléphone son assistant
particulier michel moto a estimé que le
droit avait enfin été dit je cite dans
le bon sens en reconnaissant l'absence
de preuves il a rappelé aussi que vital
kamerhe rester un acteur incontournable
de la vie politique congolaise reste à
savoir justement quelle sera sa place au
sein de la coalition au pouvoir
de son côté jimmy cannes des présidents
du réseau panafricain de lutte contre la
corruption unissent déplore je cite une
journée sombre pour la lutte contre la
corruption en rdc il s'inquiète de
l'ingérence politique en matière de
justice
et on reste en rdc où les hommages à
patrice lumumba se poursuivre soixante
et un ans après son assassinat le héros
de l'indépendance congolaise dont il ne
reste plus qu'une seule dent est à
présent de retour dans son village natal
ona loi qui l'a vu naître en 1925 et où
sont prévus deux jours dommage
le front national pour la défense de la
constitution a suspendu son appel à
manifester ce jeudi ce collectif est
connu pour avoir mené la contestation en
guinée contre l'ancien président alpha
condé dans un communiqué le fn décès dit
vouloir donner une chance au dialogue
proposé par le chef du gouvernement de
transition
maltais quitter
elle était annoncée comme la toute
première grande manifestation de
protestation contre les militaires au
pouvoir dans le pays le front national
pour la défense de la constitution a
finalement annulé la marche prévue ce
jeudi pour dénoncer selon lui la gestion
unilatérale de la transition par les
militaires face à la presse admet crédit
le collectif a dit je vous la donner une
chance au dialogue proposé par le
premier ministre de la transition
mohamed béavogui le fdc informe
l'opinion nationale et internationale
ils observent une trêve d'une semaine en
suspendant la marche citoyenne et
pacifique prévue ce jeudi 23 juin 2022
dans le grand qu'on accueille jusqu'au
30 juin 2022 afin de donner une chance à
la matérialisation du cadre de dialogue
annoncé avec des acteurs sociaux
politiques ayant des revendications sur
la conduite de la transition
toutefois le fin de ce rappel qu'en
l'absence de résultats probants pendant
cette période de suspension de son mot
d'or il se trouvera dans l'obligation de
renouveler son appel à manifester afin
d'obtenir la satisfaction de ses
revendications légitimes lundi dernier à
la télévision nationale le premier
ministre de la transition mohamed
béavogui a appelé tous les acteurs
sociaux politiques autour de la table ce
dialogue à mon cv pour ce vendredi déjà
rejetée par plusieurs partis politiques
et au mali c'est une nouvelle mission
qui attend le médiateur ouest africain
goodluck johnatan est arrivé ce jeudi à
bamako et il va engager de nouvelles
discussions avec les autorités maliennes
pour trouver des solutions aux blocages
entre la cedeao et la joie
je vous emmène à présent en côte
d'ivoire où l'état organise des
évacuations forcées massive en prévision
des pluies les autorités prévoient l'une
des plus importantes opérations de ce
type 4000 ménages seront évacués pour
vider les zones exposées aux risques
d'inondations d'effondrement et des
glissements de terrain pour la société
civile l'inquiétude concerne le sort des
riverains qui risquent de se retrouver à
la rue
reportage de samuel verbe
dans la commune d'abobo à abidjan ces
bâtiments qui menaçait de s'effondrer à
la prochaine pluie sont vidés de leurs
habitants
notifié en mars par les autorités cette
évacuation a surpris cette famille de 16
personnes qui n'a pas pu trouvé
d'alternative entre temps
fin mai le gouvernement a annoncé le
départ de 4000 ménages dans la capitale
économique ivoirienne chaque année les
saisons des pluies provoquent la mort de
plusieurs dizaines de personnes pour les
autorités il y avait donc urgence à
procéder à ces évacuations c'est la zone
était une zone sécurisée une zone plate
qu'on ne t'a pas au bord d'un ravin ne
l'a pas de raison à la fois partie
immédiatement maintenant ce qu'on fait
partie immédiatement à ce qu'ils sont
cons vous le voyez vous même on ne peut
pas laisser là en tant que gouvernement
responsable
les personnes évacuées seront logés
temporairement dans des hôtels mais
aucune solution de relogement pérenne
n'est sur la table les habitants de 54
zones à hauts risques identifiés à
abidjan risque donc eux aussi de subir
le même sort une situation que dénonce
cette association de défense des droits
de l'homme qui accompagne depuis des
années ces opérations d'évacuation les
populations sont très inquiets ce sont
des milliers des familles en continuant
d'avoir des tablettes aux questions les
sans abri la décision déloger des
personnes dans les hôtels nous pensons
qu'il n'arrive pas à régler le problème
parce que élus et vent levé les auteurs
des pressions pour combien de temps
pourquoi ne pas les dettes des petites
de relogement pour qu'ils puissent aller
chez le loger et comme appelle
probablement
25000 personnes sont visées par ce
projet global d'évacuation qui s'étendra
sur six mois l'association colombie voix
rate encore la liste exacte des sites
concernés cela pourra permettre
d'évaluer au cas par cas le bien fondé
de ces évacuations avant leur exécution
direction le soudan où un groupe de
musique issus de la minorité ethnique
des baies déjà cherche à donner une voix
aux communautés orientales du pays
longtemps marginalisée il propose un
mélange de musique traditionnelle et
d'instruments modernes avec notamment le
tombeau guitare fusion de la guitare
électrique et du tambourin le renverser
cher
[Musique]
l'histoire commence au début des années
90 lorsque noureddine jaber trouve un
manche de guitare électrique dans une
décharge de port soudan
alors âgé de 18 ans il décide de s'en
servir pour fabriquer son propre
instrument le temps bonita
à l'idée de cet instrument est venue du
riche héritage que nous avons je voulais
que le tamboura et la guitare le parlent
en même temps mais de manière différente
en 2006 noureddine forment le groupe de
repas avec cinq autres musiciens
soudanais et se donne pour mission de
faire rayonner la culture et déjà sept
tribus d'éleveurs nomades basés dans
l'est du soudan aux abords de la mer
rouge compte plus de quatre millions de
membres soit un dixième de la population
du pays mais elle a longtemps été
marginalisés notamment sous la dictature
d'omar el béchir
alliant mélodies traditionnelles aux
sonorités modernes du jazz du rock et du
blues le dernier album du groupe des
jack bauer cherche à promouvoir et
préserver l'héritage culturel de cette
ethnie oublie
[Musique]
holman régional gauche notre vision et
notre objectif principal est de
promouvoir la musique déjà afin qu'elles
ne disparaissent pas au fil des ans
après la chute d'omar el-béchir en 2019
les autorités de transition s'était
engagé à tendre la main aux minorités
non arabes du soudan et notamment les
baies déjà avant d'être renversé par un
coup d'état en automne dernier
[Musique]
et c'est sur ces notes de médias que
nous quittons une refermons ce journal
l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivis de oh la loi en passant à conakry
en passant par quelaines saint gault
rester avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]